you're looking at live pictures of an
atlas 5
rocket on the launch pad at cape
canaveral in florida
just minutes before the scheduled launch
of an ambitious nasa mission to mars
on board is the newest generation of
mars rover named
perseverance whose goal is to search for
evidence of past
life on the red planet it's the first
part of a multi-billion dollar effort
to eventually bring martian rock samples
back to earth
mark strassman shows us the challenges
ahead
this atlas 5 rocket will launch nasa's
newest explorer
destination mars perseverance is nasa's
biggest and most sophisticated rover
ever built on board 19 cameras
and lots of high-tech wizardry you're
getting an extraordinary opportunity
to see the mars helicopter before the
covet pandemic
engineer mimi yong showed us ingenuity
this four pound 80 million dollar
helicopter will photograph the martian
landscape
it would make space history flying in an
atmosphere
100 times thinner than earth which would
be more valuable the pictures that it
takes are proving that i can fly
my very very personal bias proving that
it flies
because that's going to give us the
solid foundation to build our ultimate
dream which is just much
larger aerial vehicles at mars
this mission's main goal peered deep
into the red planet's past
three and a half billion years ago water
covered mars
another nasa rover curiosity confirmed
the planet
could have supported life perseverance
hopes to establish
whether it did that's the big question
that's the big question there's a
fundamental difference between
there could have been life and there was
life absolutely yeah it's a big
big jump there project scientist ken
williford and his team
hope to find signs of ancient life
preserved here
in an ancient river delta at jezero
crater
with its robotic arm perseverance will
play astrobiologist
and drill into rock where water once
flowed
the samples it collects may hold proof
of past
microbial life think pond scum at the
edge of
the edge of a lake that would be the
galaxy's most
valuable pond scum indeed that is what
we're looking for
bringing those samples back to earth
will take two more
mind-blowing missions listen to this a
european rover will pick up the samples
a nasa rocket will launch them off the
surface of mars
and a european spacecraft will try to
catch them
mid-orbit and haul them back to earth in
2031.
if it sounds complicated it is no one
has ever
done a round trip to another planet
before lori glaze oversees
planetary science at nasa getting
samples back from mars has always been a
major goal
very ambitious but an exciting exciting
mission but first
this launch has to go right and that's
up to tori bruno and his rocket company
united launch alliance the spacecraft
has very little
capability to adjust its own trajectory
so we just have to point it exactly
right
and set it on a journey that's going to
be over 200
million miles and we do our very best to
make sure
we do everything we can to make this
successful
cruising to mars will take almost seven
months touchdown will happen
mid-february next year for cbs this
morning
mark strassman pasadena california
what an exciting mission gail and i
can't wait to see what's in the world's
most
valuable pond scum complicated
costly exciting
yup exciting is a word you guys may use
i look at it and i go
no thanks no desire and as john tower
as john tower our senior producer
pointed out he goes gail you're not on
anybody's top 10 list to go so
you don't have to worry about it he's
very good for the ego he's very good for
the ego but
i admire the people that want to go i
admire the people that want to go it's
just not for me i'm too scared
well you can stay earthbound gail